[Music]
colorblind casting is a phrase from the
1980s that is as relevant today as
renting your TV from Granada television
when we talk about decolonizing what we
often do is we want to insert a race
conversation but we never gauge that
race conversation and I'll start by
quoting Malcolm X and he says if you
stick a knife nine inches into my back
and take it out three inches well that's
not progress even if you take it all the
way out they're still not progress
unless you actually heal the wound we
haven't had any progress or any repair
foreign
[Music]
which brings us to what decolonization
is not inclusive of Multicultural but
not decolonized
why is that
many of the UK universities are trying
to incorporate decolonization into the
curriculum as a mechanism of inclusion
in the United States we talk we talk
about this as multiculturalism you're
not changing the fundamental structure
I'll take my discipline for instance if
you start asking the question what is
philosophy and you start going down say
to modernists you're doing Hobbs lock
Russo Etc and you decide to add a black
person let's say you do the voice right
what fundamentally changes about the
understanding of social contract theory
between Hobbs lock and Rousseau and then
what you put in with the boys
nothing
the idea is that Du Bois somehow wants
to be part of this Republic wants to be
covered by the social contract whereas
nothing else could be farther from the
truth
see decolonization would then take a
turn it would mean that you have to
reconceptualize what social contracts
are our black people are actually safe
and do they have Security in white
Western republics
that doesn't seem to be the case to
store it
but if you assume that they simply
wanted to be parts of Nations and
societies that killed them lynched them
enslaved them colonized them then what
does that say about the political
aspirations and the versions of Liberty
that black people and other oppressed
groups can imagine
think about that seriously as a
political theorist we aim to say that
normative values Freedom democracy
Liberty these are innate emotive and
effective qualities that generate
positive philosophy
right we want the rule of law because we
want a society that's free
but can you apply that same standard to
people who've been enslaved
Charles Mills says the difference
between black philosophy and most
euro-american and European philosophies
is that black people have always had to
deal with the problem of sub-humanity of
not being persons so the struggle that's
embedded within their philosophical
discourse from the 19th century forward
is on the basis of constantly fighting
against oppressive structures oppressive
institutions and entities that want to
manifest their inhumanity and sub
personhood as the basis of Western
democracy
so diversifying the curricula
with different figures that talk about
the Civil Rights Movement that may talk
about black abolitionism that may even
look at the symbolism of Obama being the
first black president to preside over a
white Republic
doesn't fundamentally change the
structures or the apparatus of how we
know
these figures are claimed to want us to
assimilate into white supremacist
societies they don't teach you King they
teach you Martin Luther King and UK
universities through his letter from
Birmingham Jail
they don't teach you King from where do
we go from here where he argues that we
need a revolution of values that it will
be only through God's grace that white
people can be saved from themselves
because of the evilness they've created
in racism and imperialism
see that sounds radical but that's the
model of the king that the black
community in America know
because when we look at King as a symbol
of civil rights motivation and heroism
is not because he wanted to integrate us
with our oppressors is because he stood
fast though non-violently against what
that oppression is because he understood
that the concept of humanity and of
democracy that could see black people
hate themselves that could give you
images and support segregation that had
black people live below every other
group of people in the country simply
because of the color of their skin was
not a society or a concept of democracy
that black people themselves could live
with
see that's the king that fits within the
decolonial tradition that's the king
that is supporting decline on
anti-colonial movements all throughout
the world and specifically in Latin
America that's the king that wants to
eliminate the military-industrial
complex but these are not the versions
of black people and black thought that
we're often given we're given stories
and narratives that suggest that the
Ultimate Prize of Black Liberation is
the integration into the societies of
our oppression not the fundamental
refutation of the ideas that built the
social organization that led to Black
oppression in the first place
foreign
[Music]
mathematics produced in the Egyptian
Babylonian Indian and Chinese
civilizations which where they had
developed mathematics to much higher
orders than Europe till you know the the
mid million of the last last millenna so
till 15 16th century you still had very
important contributions in mathematics
including material from algebra
indeterminate equations and the first
examples of protocalculus and so on
coming from Indian mathematical
traditions and if you look at foreign
mathematics here if you look at this you
see that this fundamentally different
than the way mathematics is understood
in Western culture Indian mathematics is
empirical not formal uh the very famous
example is of how the the metaphysics of
square root of 2 which is so influential
for the Pythagorean tradition does not
happen in Indian traditions just like
the metaphysics of negative numbers
there is no platonism and most
importantly there is no link to theology
the constant Association of mathematics
mathematical knowledge with the ideas of
theology which is very much present from
Plato onwards in the western tradition
is not available in these uh other
mathematical traditions and another very
important example is around medicine
which is something which is a living
tradition today you have powerful
cultures of knowledge of healing which
including in Indian practice today is
still used by millions of people and I I
don't have time to talk about the
examples here but we can see how people
respond to the Kobe cases in India by
drawing upon many of these medical
systems but for Western knowledge System
including the way in which medicine is
taught in India in medical schools you
know all these Traditions are not are
called as they are seen as not being
scientific and so they are not taught to
their students so this is part of the
problem of we call you know the the
colonization which has become part of
our modern knowledge systems and most
importantly
um you know when we say we talk about
decolonizing science if science is much
more than just knowledge because you
open today a book some of the most
important books on let's say history of
mathematics for example will just have a
footnote on the kind of mathematics done
in earlier civilization say and it's got
did they talk about some very ancient
Egyptian stuff about mathematics but
some of the most important work done on
mathematics in other cultural contexts
are never even mentioned as part of the
history of mathematics so there is a
creation of the idea of mathematics
which keeps aside certain kinds of
developments of mathematics in other
cultures
[Music]
thank you
so I'll start with a scientific figure
who is very influential in my research
Albert Einstein he was the person who
came up with the theory of general
relativity which is the most well
accepted theory of gravity that is known
and that's something that I use
extensively in my own work
so one of the things
Einstein did when he was confronted with
Bohr's theory of the quantum atom was
that he was horrified in fact he was so
horrified that he refused to accept it
and he told Bohr quite famously that God
doesn't play dice now quantum mechanics
is a paradigm shift in our understanding
of the world we go from determinism to
to looking at probabilities as being the
the fundamental hormone which our world
is based Einstein was a theist he
believed in an immutable God an object
that was eternal
he was not able to understand this
probabilistic interpretation of nature
he was not able to accept it when he
created general relativity
um one of the one of the solutions to
his own equations predicted that the
Universe would be expanding in an
accelerated way
that is ultimately what the observations
tell us about our universe today but
Einstein was unable to accept this fat
fact because he was obsessed with this
idea of the Eternal
so he came up with this um with this
contrived term called the cosmological
constant denoted by Capital Lambda which
he put by hand into his equations to try
to make his equations give us a static
universe
because Einstein was very clever this
actually worked out in his favor after
his death because this is the simplest
model we have of something called dark
energy which puppetedly is supposed to
be responsible for the expansion of the
universe we don't really know what it is
70 percent of the entire universe do you
see what I mean about asking scientists
to be humble we don't know what 70 of
what we're made up of actually is
but let me talk about Einstein the man
himself
um he when he moved to the institute for
advanced study in Princeton
he was he was a he was an outspoken
advocate for anti-racist beliefs and
ideologies in the U.S
so one of the things he said commented
on American racism was he called it the
nation's worst disease he had recently
some papers were found or letters he had
written on his own travels when he
traveled to China where he called
Chinese people industrial filthy and
obtuse
so
this is not my effort to try to Sally
Einstein's character but just my effort
to show you that making Heroes of people
institutions or concepts is a very
dangerous practice and also to show you
that a scientist no matter how brilliant
and how famous and how much their
contribution has been to the fields that
they are working in they are not without
cultural constant context had signed I
had Einstein not been a theist would he
have accepted quantum mechanics earlier
would we have had a theory of quantum
gravity I don't know
foreign
[Music]
Thomas was a person who owes his
appointment and Confirmation to an
intersectional failure
and this is where we come to the story
about Anita Hill so um Clarence Thomas
was a person who was nominated by the
first Bush
there were many African-Americans and
liberals who initially opposed him
heating Thurgood Marshall he was the
first African-Americans warning that
having a black person on the Supreme
Court was no guarantee that they would
lift up civil rights and so consequently
many opposed Clarence Thomas looking for
someone with a a deeper background in
supporting advocating
civil rights expansion and ensuring that
the existing hard-fought rights were
going to be upheld by the Supreme Court
however at a crucial moment Anita Hill
was flown to Washington DC by the Senate
Judiciary Committee to testify about her
experiences when she was working with
Clarence Thomas in previous positions
when she told told her testimony
Clarence Thomas denounced the testimony
and the hearing as a high-tech lynching
that was reserved for uppity Negroes who
deemed it important to think for
themselves
now many saw this as a decisive race
claim that demanded solidarity across
the racial terrain for any people who
saw themselves as part of the racial
Justice Coalition now despite the fact
that there's no recorded history of
anyone ever being lynched for anything
that was done to a black woman it still
worked partly because lynching tells a
story about the American Experience of
white supremacy that focuses on the
sexual repression and Punishment of
African-American men when he was able to
say that the fact that she was herself a
black woman the fact that this has never
been the response to abuse of black
women just was utterly irrelevant
and as a consequence millions of people
moved to Clarence Thomas's side and
began to Advocate to their Senators the
need to confirm him uh as against this
effort This Racist effort to keep him
off of the court I have to say having
been there at the at the hearing and
seeing him say that almost fell out of
my chair
um Clarence Thomas was never known as an
advocate for racial Justice never known
as one who looked back at history to use
that to think about what was happening
in a contemporary this was just a
one-off moment to wrap himself in you
know the tragedy of a particular racial
history at a time that it had nothing to
do with what was actually happening now
um part of the reason that was
successful is because of the
intersection Erasure of the way that
racism was experienced by black women in
particular an Erasure around the fact
that sexual harassment itself sexual
harassment law actually began with
African-American women suing employers
for race and gender discrimination as
experienced through uh harassing
Behavior what many people who supported
Clarence Thomas often said
that suggested how much ignorance there
was about that story was that sexual
harassment wasn't something that black
women were concerned with sexual
harassment was
um a preoccupation of
um American
white women built off of the history of
Puritans when it comes to sexuality and
so it has nothing to do with
discrimination and nothing to do with
African-American women
thank you
so I think this is a complicated
question largely because I come from the
United States where white liberals and
white supremacists actually share a
great disdain for black people broadly
so when we talk about group things are
the pursuit of an idea that one group
has a certain kind of knowledge base our
Authority on certain matters
in white institutions that usually leads
to the representation of the people
white liberals choose what group they
want to Advocate on behalf of has very
little to do with truth and more on
political interests so the Quest for
victimization the Quest for the kinds of
identities that cannot be questioned in
many ways acts against the radical
Traditions that oppress people have made
explored and taught for centuries in the
UK I've been quite surprised because
despite the relatively low numbers of
people of color there's still this
insistence by why liberals that certain
positions should not be heard and even
when those people are absent be they
black brown Etc white liberals can act
on behalf of them now this is no
different than what we also see on the
right in the United States for instance
I was censored when I was at Texas A M
precisely because I offended white
supremacists I don't know how you don't
offend white supremacists if you're
black but nonetheless the accusation by
the president was that a black person or
a black professor offended white
supremacist now in that situation Nation
given that the Board of Trustees at
Texas A M were sympathetic to the
alt-right there was a call to censor me
a call to kick me out a call to make
sure that the alt-right and the growing
Republican consensus did not discuss
race racism or white supremacy as a
structural apparatus of American society
the effect of that was that years later
you had the same people a same group of
people that had power claimed that they
could not be attacked with reason they
suggested rather than debate the
marriage of critical race Theory our
white supremacy as a structural
apparatus our cultural ideological
phenomena that those simply banned the
teaching of critical race Theory and
black history and universities and
courses so the question of group think
becomes relatively important for how we
think about which groups were situated I
think what ultimately happens especially
in the UK is that this becomes
bifurcated in a very left and liberal
versus conservative right ideology but
coming from the United States and then
being placed in the UK you can see that
there's a muting on both sides the
reactionism that you get from the right
is one that doesn't want to engage or
look at the colonial histories that have
formed the basis of British Society
universities have less than one percent
black people black professors are black
and other minorities there but yet they
speak on behalf of them as if their
experiences can be translated and
transferred to how white liberals see
themselves a bunch of middle as white
people arguing that their right identity
politics makes them the most victimized
despite their economic and political
privilege and on behalf of them arguing
for people certain kind of voices are
pushed out and now many people will
think that that's actually progress that
we're actually advocating for people who
are silenced who are absent who need to
be represented but you have to ask
yourself a question with those people
that are not there actually choose the
white liberal to be their spokesperson
would they actually in fact prefer that
those voices can actually accurately
represent them and in a world where they
can't how many of the white liberals
would then silence the black radicalism
or the black anarchism or the black
Socialism or the afro-pessimism that
doesn't align with their political
ideology would we be so apt to say that
British Society is fundamentally racist
if we take a critical race Theory
perspective and if that violates some of
the political sensibilities that the
left has what then happens to those
people that they said they Advocate on
behalf of do they simply disagree with
black people enough to still advocate
for them or do they have to displace
those radical voices for more humanists
and Progressive tones but this doesn't
let the right off the hook either in
this country I've been quite surprised
because this very debate about group
think right this very essence of who
should be listened to and who should be
silenced plays on a very very ugly ways
culturally so whereas United States is a
very racially stratified Society where
you know if you're black or white you
fit on certain sides of a political
Spectrum here there's the idea that we
can embrace the notion that we're
colorblind and we're human beings and
from that perspective groups that think
differently that are trying to introduce
racial different sexual difference Etc
seem to be this ones that are ultimately
trying to disrupt the culture so I think
the question again a group thing becomes
one that's very important but it doesn't
become the kind of situation where it's
whether or not truth is had or truth is
not had ultimately it's a question of
who controls power and who allows the
people to be heard and represented as
having the truthful perspective and
unfortunately that's led us to a
misguided liberalism that prefers
colorblindness rather than a rigorous
radical tradition our critical
intervention of social equality
[Music]
I mean I just talking about Richard II
and the production that she did what do
you think of an argument that's if a
woman of color goes to that production
she's not the only woman of color in the
room for once you know as adults being
quoted saying is that something
worth doing I mean like we have to
operate within the constraints that
we're in right and I remember going to
an all black cast of um Julius Caesar
and being really powerful
um and this is obviously a positive
thing to do but it's a much bigger
problem than that why why did we send to
Shakespeare so much like Shakespeare is
great but there's other stuff out there
why do we Center these same stories and
same narratives and if you have to in
order to get some kind of diversity or
historical you have to keep putting
black and Asian characters into into you
know miscast intent historically and
that's telling you you're telling the
wrong stories there's plenty of stories
about Britain that would involve us and
that we would be in automatically and so
the bigger thing is how do you tell a
different range of Stories the better
reflect our actual Society
but you do that as well is the point
okay you do that as well so that kids
are going to be taught Shakespeare so
let them come and see if you know we're
in a black box we're not in you know
Rome or Denmark we're in Stratford in
Manchester or whatever so you have to do
them all that's that's why this new
Netflix thing I'm doing we have a mixed
race Queen Charlotte because she was
mixed race and we have people of all
stratas in that show because there were
there were people of all structures in
that show I just think we have we have
to try and cover everything because the
downfall of the the super State as we
know it is not coming anytime soon and
we have to let our children see
themselves you know the difference
between my cousin who went to study
medicine in America who'd grown up in
Ghana and his cut and his classmates who
were born and raised in America in terms
of how they viewed the possibilities for
who they could be in the world was
striking because everybody in Ghana from
the road sweeper to the president looked
like my cousin and it wasn't same
experience for those other children in
his class at med school and he was kind
of shocked by how truncated their
Horizons were so
you know I think we just have to try and
expand that Vision as much as we can but
fundamentally you're right unless we
have the downfall of this state as we
know it
it's all winter dressing and we do what
we can
[Music]
actually the objectively Britain is a
great place to live I'm going to come
back to this because that's actually
really important point right so if
you're thinking about the problem with
this question is that it suggests that
these sins are in the past and actually
these things aren't in the past racism
is not in the past it is still very much
in the present and I'll start by quoting
Malcolm X Malcolm's my favorite you'll
hear a lot of Malcolm X quotes from me
and he says if you stick a knife nine
inches into my back and take it out
three inches well that's not progress
even if you take it all the way out
they're still not progress unless you
actually heal the wound we haven't had
any progress or any repair and if you
actually look at the and I'll just use
black people in the Caribbean as an
example because I've got three minutes
and it's quite a good example if you
just use that as an example you would
say the knife isn't even out it's
actually still about six inches deep
right so my family and you'll let your
family from the Caribbean brought over
there as slaves right with nothing with
the literally had the had had
exploitation and resource is beat out of
us right now we think because slavery
finished in 1838 that somehow was done
it's over well no what happened at the
end of slavery was the biggest
government bailout in history to the
slave owners money which you can track
today which is still in the economy and
my your all of our both of our
descendants were left with nothing and
had to keep doing work like slaves for
nothing and were deeply impoverished
still for the Next Generation Jamaica
was a colony of Britain for a whole
generation Jamaica is still basically
economy of Britain if we were 100 honest
and so when our parents came over our
grandparents came over to the UK they
came with nothing right they came to the
mother country expecting to be treated
well and what did they find racism more
racism couldn't get housing couldn't get
jobs etc etc etc and the fact that a
couple of us a few a few of us have done
well I do I'm doing very very well right
doesn't change the fact let's look at
the evidence the black youth
unemployment rate today is exactly the
same as it was in 1980 the wealth gap
which is ex enormous where does that
wealth get come from we were built over
a slaves we went we had no wealth and
we're poor because of that why is
Britain a great place to live because of
the wealth exploited from our backs so
if you look at somewhere like Jamaica
which is one of the poorest countries in
the world you tell me that racism is
dead it's not dead it's still there it's
not past that's what reparations is
about not about apologies or not about
individuals it's about looking at the
whole and saying actually that gap of
wealth is still there and that racism
still affects all of our Lives to do
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign